here comes somebody life right here
where's your wife won't you get your
wife to chime in she send a video do you
know what we believe in it chin
Harborside son man hi my wife watch us
thinking you're full of [ __ ] yeah we got
four videos from your side peace and
nothing from your lady step up prove her
wrong dog I saw him hanging out with her
and her nieces putting wigs on him and
stuff that was pretty fun adorable yeah
where did you post that at stories
waking up these children brah beautiful
dog it's beautiful [ __ ] [ __ ] everybody
in here should say there's save their
stories and send them to me before the
show so we can look at stuff up
you know she caroling up nothing judging
it's a trigger for an appeal I'm just
gonna curl up and read a good book she
seems like the type that says that you
know I said I'm just gonna curl up
really good dude I bet she curls up read
the book and bakes that apple pie dog
that might be wifey for you Theo
she has a well-read little bro well now
you called her a [ __ ] we just met her
looks like that little word she looks
like that little worm that comes out the
Apple you know I'm saying with the class
we got [ __ ] up maybe we don't eat me
yeah oh I don't know why that Apple
you're raising the rent she beautiful
man yes
and when you see when you see a pie you
forget how good it is yeah you forget
how good a pie is until you see a
picture of a pie bring up a picture of a
pie name yeah Marie Marie Callender's
why don't ya cuz they fake brother cuz
i'll know all the sold was pie it's 2020
bro selling sugar shapes but i they
didn't sell realized pot show me some
real pop
that's that sugar disk there I'll tell
you right now I like a nice pecan pie
myself do you
Oh with a cup of coffee or pecan nothing
more unhealthy in the pecan pie though
oh yeah the sugar you put in when you're
making a pecan pie man it's bags of
sugar you need seven eight bags bro you
like cherry pie huh you like a cherry
I don't mind it bright if it has real
cherries in it I don't like them fake
gas cherries yeah sometime they'll get
pieces or uh something else over cherry
flavor on it
that should fantastic little have pie
enough man do you probably had a lot
about pie growing up in the Midwest on
Nick I bet I was never a big sweet guy
that's right yeah I got a lot of [ __ ]
for that but yeah the people I feel a
mom I like meat and potatoes most people
like losing their teeth over sweets bro
Nick's like basketball man I'm trying to
lose my teeth off ridiculous yeah Rob
Dyrdek's my dentist yeah I'm pissed
people didn't film everything back then
I would love down Rob Dyrdek's my sweet
tooth I'll tell you right now man I love
[ __ ] pie though homemade pie all day
is that what she's asking homemade or
store-bought treats know about some
[ __ ] Little Debbie can suck it oh
she makes a nice help me up I'll give
her that
no yeah we'll say you never put enough
icing you know yeah they do
[Music]
hey not for me dude huh not for me bro
Malloy [ __ ] filled to the brim with
icing it is filled to the brim bro know
you can get bigger ones now you get the
giant patties which it's a step in the
right direction first of all we never
call anything from Little Debbie a patty
okay cause a patty
Nick knows what the [ __ ] time is his
ass how to open your pie the other day
in here I did because they were out of
Swiss cake rolls that's really my go to
Little Debbie I love a nice Swiss cake
roll that little thick dude could they
put more chocolate on the Swiss cake
though it's so thin yeah oh you sound
like a company man no I like I like my
[ __ ] fancy you sound like a complaint of
Potamus dog Oh
yeah yeah and I just wanted thicker yeah
just get to man so they ain't gonna
change the whole business model dude I
feel like I should sue Oreo because for
the longest I was a kid I should sue
Oreo Hibiscus to take up space in this
dude's hard drive lawsuits against his
check this out man they came out with
mega stuff when I was a kid I used to
crack them open and then put all the
icing on the one and make a thick ass
Oreo see him yeah quadruple stuff [ __ ]
yeah and then they're like oh mega stuff
they took that [ __ ] for me idea yeah
yeah I think they get that mega stuff
don't I'm fool you with the mega I
thought you wanted more stuffing in it
now you don't want more stuff no because
the mega stuff ain't actually mega stuff
do I get the double stuffed the double
stuffed actually thicker
what's animation [ __ ] a kid with sweet
teeth knows dude that mega stuff that's
fake that's fake news I told you dude
that's fake news bro it's that Michael
Rapaport huh yeah fake news fake belt
totally fake news fake belt dude you
know that right fake nose fake belt
do they ever have a [ __ ] McFlurry you
have to McFlurry oratorio right yeah
that's a good one FFF they put some
horsepower behind that thing because we
get the spoon that thing is let's it
because that's how they mix it look I
would love to meet you just trying to
curl up with a warm bookings a piece of
warm apple pies yeah I read a book the
other day man so nobody believed in that
Brennan is a reading denier first of all
let's don't doubt that man Jim what do
you think about this lady and he's these
goods I know that a sugar is a real
combatant
of a lot of Asian cultures now I wanted
to see kind of what you thought no it's
where me and Nick actually have
something common I'm not a sweets person
you know this right sure you know
there's no [ __ ] terrorist
what is it actually we get a lot in
common oh yeah well this is another
thing we have a cop this guy uses all fm
yeah I drink sweet stuff all the time
non Sevilla with real stevia instead of
sugar there's no sugar in there yeah
drink sweet stuff that but that's so
sweet
okay and what should we tell the lady
though you think oh oh ho made a hundred
percent yeah homemade but homemade you
can't go sideways man has to be just
know what the [ __ ] she's doing around
that kitchen you know I'm saying do you
think she doesn't know nah operated
kitchen she filmed the video in the
kitchen Brendan yeah I've seen that pie
from Costco though you know I'm saying
get that big apple pie from Costco she
ain't fooling nobody I know my [ __ ]
sweet little let's go back and look at
that pie for a second [ __ ] because I
don't believe it I didn't like the thing
that she said you know manufactured
sweets I don't what the [ __ ] those
chocolate discs
death she brought to the screen there
what was that look at this this she's
from Canada celebration cookies bro the
celebration cook what brand is that
that's a sweeter e it's a sweeter e
Brett's a local sweeter in Canada
Leclerc it looks like yeah she's much
realer so and bang mm-hmm that three
hole puncher right there for that
frickin hair and apple pie when that
dude got caught [ __ ] the pie huh you
remember that an apple pie in American
Pie oh yeah yeah I loved all three of
them you did all three of them
great great sear I tried to holler at
Tara Reid one time I know how'd that go
I don't think it went a lot Terry
huh was the hot one - no she's hot for a
long time and that's kind of my little
crazy
y'all thick this is after crazy I think
ah perfect time but she had a boyfriend
or something so I didn't do it how did
you didn't do anything
Oh in my mind I tried hollering you feel
me that brain holler like oh she knows
what could have happened she's in Van
Wilder - hell yes she was shooter shoe
bro shooter shoot
you're on sidelines dreaming about
shooting yeah but also people are
the shooting ain't that safe man look at
all these people shooting at these women
out of here I did Shen's since Sharon
Stone a DM one time how long ago was
this though years ago probably six
months ago Wow huh I'm here back then
your back Sharon Stone's attic instinct
uh she makes headstones you know Sharon
Stone you know Sharon Stone's oh place
she's in casino you look up Sharon
Stone's that's what you try to do chewed
her in case I don't know houses bang her
her and her and uh what's that move her
Sylvester Stallone he's Rambo know their
snipers yeah no she's in totally good
cause she's in totally she said I'm not
chicken total recall mara when he dreams
about a girl it's her Total Recall
the specialist that [ __ ] is fire yeah
she's the white Elijah douche Cobra
bring up bring her up Reese all this
isn't ol recall Sharon Stone dude she
[ __ ] him over - but she's such a
baddie see they tried recreate Total
Recall zarnold Total Recall was good I
remember when he goes out sighs all we
suffocating I remember the three breasts
Brian I remember a couple bullets Nessa
you don't remember when when he puts the
thing up his nose and pulls it out the
tractor of his nose huh
I don't have true lies that was a good
one she losses okay who's about driving
in Key West and how hard it is all right
let's see what else do we have man
that's it
[Music]
the king nothing
[Music]